(instrumental pop music)
- Ladies, it's Sabastian.
- Hey, can I get a whiskey neat?
- [Bartender] Sure.
- Thanks.
- Hey, come on, bartender, I
want to make my order here.
Okay, bartender, listen
up, this is what I want.
Give me something like vodka, but not gin,
something like vodka, and I want something
with no carbonation in
a nice strong glass.
(instrumental pop music)
- I'm sorry, my bad.
- What up, bro?
- Sorry, sorry.
- I'm just going to charge
my phone, is that okay?
Yeah.
(techno pop music)
Sebastian.
Oh, yeah.
Hey, what's up?
Did you know in French
class, they called me
Monsieur Sebastian de la tornade,
which means Mr. Sebastian of the Tornado.
Powerful and nice.
- Hey, hey, Sebastian, hey, Sebastian.
- What's up bro?
- They want you over at the pool table.
They called your name, yeah.
- They want the tornado.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Awesome.
- [Red Shirt] Sorry about that guy.
- It's fine.
(techno pop music)
(snoring and mumbling)